foreign
[Music]
you will learn how to troubleshoot and
resolve node not ready state in a Google
kubernetes engine or gke cluster before
we jump into troubleshooting let's
review how GK nodes work a gke cluster
consists of worker missions or compute
engine VMS referred to as nodes which
run your containerized applications and
other workloads the GK control plane
manages the node lifecycle such as
automatic upgrades repairs health checks
and no data scaling
creating updating and deleting nodes is
done through compute engine apis
node pools create the instance Group
which creates GCE VMS with the
kubernetes binaries to register the
nodes with the gke control plane
the nodes have two states ready and not
ready the ready State means the node is
available to run workloads
but what does a node not ready status
mean it indicates the node cannot run
the workload a node is marked as not
ready when the required node conditions
which we will discuss shortly are not
met
you can view the status of the nodes
using the cloud console or using Cube
cuddle get nodes command
here is the list of conditions that are
checked before gke marks a node as ready
to schedule parts
if any of the conditions are not met the
node is marked with not ready status
let's dive into the demo and learn how
to troubleshoot and resolve two common
scenarios when a node is marked as not
ready
container runtime down
container Network initialization or cni
failures
first scenario in the Google Cloud
console go to the kubernetes engine
clusters page
and click on your cluster name
I'll select GK hyphen cluster
navigate to the nodes tab which lists
all the nodes associated with the
cluster
oops this node is marked as not ready
click the specific node name and check
the conditions section
as a warning container runtime is down
and ready false
this warning indicates that the
container runtime is down which has cost
gke to Mark the node as not ready
note that you can also find this
information by logging into the node
using SSH and running the system CTL
status
containerd.service command
to fix this issue check if node Auto
Repair is enabled on the Node pool as it
is enabled in our node pool GK Will
Repair the node and bring it back to
ready state
a the node is back to ready state
now let's troubleshoot another scenario
where a node is marked as not ready
from the Google Cloud console go to the
kubernetes engine clusters node tab
click the name of the node and check the
conditions section
this time the warning is container
runtime network not ready Network ready
is equal to false
CNA plugin not initialized and ready
false this message indicates the
container network is not ready
triggering the GK in to Mark the node as
not ready
to investigate this further in the
Google Cloud console go to the network
intelligence Network analyzer page check
if there are any firewall rules blocking
connectivity to the API server oh the
network analyzer is highlighting egress
traffic is blocked due to the firewall
rule
there you go this could be causing the
note to be marked as not ready to
mitigate this issue disable the firewall
rule by clicking edit and selecting
disabled under enforcement
you can now see the enforcement
displaying as disabled
let's verify if this issue is still
present by refreshing the node page
oh no it looks like the issue is not to
solved yet
our next step is to validate non-jke
managed web books that are running in
the cluster as misconfigured webos
intercept and prevent system parts from
starting
in the cloud console go to the cloud
logging look for events of type k8's
cluster and filter based on the cluster
name
search for log entries with the text
failed calling Web book
there are a number of entries for a book
named check ignore label blue dot sh
let's switch to the terminal and run
Cube cuddle get validating web of
configurations to narrow down the
webbook
the blue validating webbook
configuration has two webos
run the cube cuddle kit validating Web
book configurations command to list the
output in yaml format
the section check ignore label.blue sh
shows that a failure policy is said to
fail the scope and the resources show
the webbook is intercepting all
resources for the entire cluster scope
across all namespaces indicated by star
keep in mind kubernetes best practices
recommend avoiding webwork operations on
Cube system namespace to mitigate this
issue modify the webbook configuration
to exclude the cube system namespace
from the terminal run Cube cuddle edit
validating webo configuration navigate
to the check ignore label blue.ss
section and change the scope to
namespaced and add the namespace cube
system under the namespace selector
adding the namespace selector with not
in condition ensures the webbook doesn't
operate in the cube system namespace
let's go back to the kubernetes engine
clusters page in Cloud console
click the node Tab and verify the status
of the node a the node is now marked as
ready thanks for watching
[Music]